hello and welcome to this video playing
a AVC 1964 so take off with an English
today probably and happy you can always
transpose in this opening this time it's
probably going to transpose to a ready
yep let's transpose to a ready system or
reti opening yeah so c5 yeah I'd like to
take in this case preventing black from
advancing with them with deform ya hear
this is going to you continue like that
knight c6 now I have e4e 45 gaining
quite a bit of space so he's going to
take it everywhere ok yeah this type of
position is often a little bit
uncomfortable for black because of the
weekend structure on the queenside here
this is a typical continuation Knight c3
I can answer with 94 which is in a very
important point otherwise this would be
good for black I mean yeah Queenie one
macro Wallace is irrelevant 94 strong
this is some also what analyzed for my
English opening series that is now out
also untestable it's been on just 24 for
quite a while already and now we made a
chess of a release of that as well so
let's see what we
you hear a couple of options I can just
continue to play against the Suppan or
can take it can just take it however
then grouped eh I don't really have a
great square for the Queen I think I'm
yeah so where is the queen actually
where should it be placed it's also easy
to say this one maybe with the tempo
tempo only H pawn ok and now yeah I
think I should cover this and keep the
option of your queen to c5 I was
thinking it's a bit a bit annoying for
him to face is heaven as hanging maybe
queen should be two is actually a move
but I can play rook e1 just covering
this and yeah I control the most
important squares here if he plays rooks
e7 I have clinch a queen 85 is a double
attack why is that not winning material
think it should with material a double
attack against something on a dark
square in on a light square is always
very difficult to to address usually
only the Queen can cover both and it's
not going to happen here black resigned
yeah was a bit of an opening disaster um
get this is a a very young sound line
for black actually he should probably
take on d4 as he did 96
now it is just not particularly i'm
particularly great i think when I'm
knight c6 immediately is probably what
you should do let's see 64 and then take
this is not so comfortable if he goes
here i have a form something like that
I'm not completely sure about my
recommendation in the in my own
repertoire in five I think it was
something like that and here white is
better with more space maybe just night
to d2 or something something like that
it's not very nice for him one-eyed c4
maybe yeah all this is fairly passive
[Music]
again this is a slightly better position
for wide my idea is to go night you 45
anyway and 93 just doesn't help at all
because of this move yeah he has no good
reply now if he takes on d1 a check
actually play this intermediate move
this is also very good for why them but
i can actually already take here taking
the book the end the system and the game
position which is very nice I gained a
tempo by Quincy too and now you can
actually are you what to do I don't have
to play Bishop f3 but it definitely is a
somewhat sensible looking move and the
engine actually agrees forgot to switch
it on engine actually agrees that this
is one of the better moves rook capn
Quincy five is already annoying i'm
attacking this and he has no natural
cover if he goes here I wanted to play
rook e1 yes and I don't really see how
he now addresses this a7 is just
completely hanging
this is not working like in the game
it's it's pretty pretty awkward right
here he reside you can't win quickly
with the opening slide we're ready
sometimes um it is often yeah more
poisonous than you might think ok guys
thanks for watching